ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States hit me
with your worst guys I'm wired up and
I'm like that tall drink of dog piss
James Comey you can ask me absolutely
anything with mr. Tommy's testimony
accurate no I don't know look I don't
know a lot of things like whether or not
we have troops and cutter do we I think
we do but we don't like them we don't
like them did you or did you not tell
Jim told me to drop the investigation
into Michael Flynn I didn't tell him
anything I said I hope he could let it
go and folks I hope a lot of things I'm
a hopeful guy I believe and this is a
phrase I just invented in the audacity
of hope' have your presidency been
permanently damaged by the testimony
today it wasn't testimony it was a
circus the whole thing was a big stunt
and that's tonight's theme stunts all
this stuff with Comey and Russia is a
total distraction from what we should be
focusing on infrastructure and folks our
structure has the best infra rivaled
only by our tremendous OUTFRONT
homie said quote lordy I hope there are
tapes of your conversations are there
lord I hope not
why shouldn't we get a straight answer
out of you when it comes to answers on
the Liberace of being straight my lawyer
says I'm the president call me believe
it
let's roll